allora l'ora è tarda quindi buonanotte
dovete essere completamente svegli
perché io non sono qui a raccontarvi che
ho inventato cose strane non ho scoperto
buchi neri non ho costruito ponti io
sono ammirato dei miei colleghi delle
persone che hanno parlato prima di me
perché davvero mi hanno stupito e io
invece questa sera mi presento tra
l'altro già abbastanza depresso perché
qualche settimana fa
mio figlio ha portato a casa un brutto
voto abbiamo avuto una discussione a un
certo punto non mi fa non dovresti
parlarmi così esala cosa prendeva una
bruttissima piega meglio perché non
dovrei parlarti così papà chiariamoci
mio figlio di 18 anni quindi come tutti
i padri e le madri che hanno figli
adolescenti o in via di uscita
mi possono capire la mia autostima è
sotto i tacchi perché mi ha risposto
chiariamoci bene papà io non sono uno di
quelli che paga per sentirti parlare e
quindi è capiterà anche a voi prima dai
ragazzi entro dentro nell'argomento
subito perché è il tema è inedito e io
vi volevo parlare di qualcosa che forse
come diceva faust all'inizio ha più a
che fare con la riscoperta di qualcosa
di molto molto antico e forse
dimenticato che altro io di mestiere
francamente faccio il manager è mia e
sono appassionato ed è diventata una
professione quello di occuparmi di
motivazione mia e poi ho scoperto che
interessava anche ad altre quindi io di
queste cose parlo
e a queste cose mi rifaccio quello che
volevo proporvi stasera è
sostanzialmente una
una ipotesi è che non ha nessuna volontà
di stoccare al cento per cento di
risolvere le vostre vite io sono qui in
funzione di testimone e non tanto di
predicatore o di qualcuno di guru di
santone che ha la verità in tasca
l'idea sarebbe quella di dare degli
spunti che riescano ad agevolare le
persone ad avere un futuro edito quanto
più vicino possibile al progetto di vita
che avevano in testa
questa è una cosa che a me interessa
molto e se leggete nel sottotitolo
costruire il proprio futuro mettendosi
al riparo da kaos caso e cattiveria mi
riferisco a un fatto che io incontro
ogni giorno lo incontro per me è un
incontro con le persone che lavorano con
me siamo esposti a una complessità e una
variabilità tale ti anche alla
cattiveria data dal sistema competitivo
che io non mi azzardo a giudicare però
c'è che i nostri progetti di vita quasi
mai trovano una una una stesura una un
aderenza poi con l'air e con la realtà
come si fa a sbagliare il meno possibile
come si fa a fare sì che il proprio
progetto il copione del proprio film la
trama del proprio libro e proprio
romanzo siano i più derenti possibile la
realtà come vedete io ho indossato non a
caso questa maglietta perché qualcuno di
voi conoscerà sì o no qualcuno ascolta
dai bui nessuno beh questo comunque è
l'album lazarus dove cioè contenuto
black star l'ho indossata perché mi è
venuto in mente mentre preparavo questo
speech che david bowie per esempio è una
di quelle rare persone che durante la
vita è riuscito a dare molta aderenza
tra il copione che aveva in testa e la
sua vita è questa per esempio non so se
avete seguito le ultime vicissitudini
della sua vita e questo album è venuto
fuori praticamente un giorno un giorno e
mezzo prima che lui morisse ed è venuto
fuori il giorno del suo compleanno
come dire perfino la chiusura della vita
di questo grande artista è stata molto
aderente al suo progetto questa cosa a
me affascina ripeto non con l'intento di
sistemare al cento per cento
le nostre possibilità di fare ciò che
vogliamo della vita terra di avvicinarci
quanto più possibile questo sono io per
cominciare questo sono io
a 30 anni era appena entrato
nell'azienda in cui sarei rimasto poi
per 25 anni un'azienda di abbigliamento
e credo che non far torto a nessuno se
dico che si chiama di essere un'azienda
in cui ho lasciato definitivamente il
cuore ma non è questo che volevo dirvi è
che io sono molto contento di fare
fotocopie in questo momento ha da pochi
giorni che sono stato assunto perché mi
ero trovato pochi giorni prima davanti a
un bivio decisionale importante era
davanti al presidente di questa azienda
persona perché io francamente a cui devo
molto e che adoro che mi fa
sostanzialmente un discorso di questo
tipo nei cie guarda ti darò meno di
quello che ti danno dall'altra parte non
ti darò l'auto aziendale io facevo il
venditore venditore di tessuti e ti darà
o meno di quello che ti danno dall'altra
parte non diventerai mai dirigente
perché i dirigenti questa azienda mi
basta le mie avanzano e io che in quel
momento il mondo passarmi davanti a
aspiravano entrare in questa azienda
fatta da gente che sembrava più rock
star che che che che manager e io mi
aspettavo mi vedete tutto quanto il
mondo che mi passava davanti perché in
quel mentre a 30 anni come tanti della
mia età io ho 55 anni
a quel tempo tuali già un mutuo per
l'appartamento un punto per l'automobile
tua moglie o mutuo per le tende un muto
per la tv e pensavo quando tornerò a
casa sarà il disastro ha accettato un
lavoro in cui guadagno meno non era
bella d'altra parte però il presidente
tira fuori un biglietto tipo questo
quasi uguale a questo me lo tira addosso
dice però in cambio di tutto questo io
ti offro questo bigliettino e con questo
bigliettino tu la vita andrai dove due
vorrai la cosa per quanto aromatica
possa sembrare non è qui che volevo fare
il punto mi ispira a dire che questo è
stato uno dei bivi quelle sliding doors
e in cui tu decidi di andare in un posto
piuttosto che in un altro e fra poco
capirete perché vi dico che tutti quanti
questi bv decisionali sono esattamente
uno dei punti da analizzare per avere
una trama di un libro un copione di un
film che aderisca poi alla realtà
io in quel caso ho scelto per entrare in
questa azienda è questa si è rivelata
per me poi una scelta giusta ma quante
altre volte ho sbagliato
ho sbagliato un sacco di volte adesso io
questa sera ripeto all'inizio ero molto
concentrato su di me e sul mio discorso
però pensato che alla fine era più
importante concentrarmi sulla gente che
mi sta davanti a vedere se riesco a
lasciare un buon ricordo e quindi tutti
quanti questi vili che analizziamo ci
portano sempre disorientamento
decideremo bene o decideremo male c'è
gente di talento che li sceglie male c'è
gente di meno talento che invece poi
sceglie dei vivi in cui i cigli delle
strade è un bivio che le porterà a stare
bene è un po la legge del piano
inclinato e una volta messi su un piano
inclinato le biglie per hannover celler
aree fino a un certo punto è a meno che
non intervengano grandi attriti
differente la viscosità dell'area la
rugosità del terreno
comunque la pallina tenderà andare
avanti e un po così le nostre vite
davanti a dei b b quindi il bivio è un
momento davvero importante in cui decide
cosa fare e come si fa a sbagliare il
meno possibile
devo scomodare with che stai una grande
mente un matematico e un filosofo
austriaco considerato una grandi menti
del ventesimo secolo
diceva occhio fra i mille cose anche
molto complicate che diceva sono le
domande che ti poni che creano il tuo
mondo e io sono molto convinto che la
domanda fondamentale sia questa che è il
boss chi o cosa
dirige delle nostre vite ecco chiedersi
chi è il vostro secondo me è davvero una
domanda intelligente che naturalmente
dalla notte dei tempi che ce la facciamo
di solito le religioni rispondono o
senza entrare in quale regione io ho la
mia voi avrete dalla nostra ma le
religioni fanno un'opera di
sistematizzazione e ti danno una
pregiudiziale un credo che a priori
risolve gran parte della risposta alla
domanda chi è il boss quindi c'è una
verità indiscutibile assoluta e questa è
una maniera con cui molti di noi
sistemano ed hanno senso alle loro vite
altre persone invece sono più
predisposte o decidono di abbracciare
l'idea che la risposta sia il fato il
destino quindi sostanzialmente non è una
mia responsabilità quella di far fronte
agli effetti della mia vita
altri invece si spostano l'alfa e
l'omega di questo spettro e dicono no
tutto quanto è cambiato le tutto quanto
è sotto la mia giurisdizione
se mi do sufficientemente da fare
posso ottenere ciò che voglio dalla mia
vita per me
naturalmente la domanda fondamentale che
volevo proporvi anche l'idea
fondamentale che voglio proporvi è
questo
queste risposte che ci siamo date dati
ci portano ad agire differentemente
nella vita sotto penso che sia il
destino il fato tu andrai una certa
direzione barry schwartz se n'è accorto
se tu è uno psicologo che dice se tu
credi che sia il destino sarai supino se
tu credi che sia tutto dentro la tua
volontà
sarai proattivo sostanzialmente gli dice
è la tecnologia delle idee le idee danno
la stura al mondo che noi creiamo e
quindi mi sono chiesto stasera cosa
potevo condividere con un pubblico come
questo
un'idea che fosse sufficientemente laica
e approcciabile da tutti senza dover
fare atti di fede e l'idea che mi sono
fatto io è questa che sia importante per
scegliere bene i vivi decisionali della
nostra vita essere capace di collegare
bene a temi passati presenti e futuri
vi chiedo di aspettare un attimo per
capire meglio quello che volevo darvi e
intanto prendere solamente questo spunto
collegare meglio passato presente e
futuro per decidere meglio i bivi e
rendere più aderente il nostro progetto
alla realtà
quali sono le problematiche del
collegare passato presente e il futuro è
una è che se noi ci vediamo come un io
differente in questi momenti c'è una
disparità c'è una disparità di peso dei
nostri
io gli faccio un esempio se noi dobbiamo
intraprendere una dieta
c'è un conflitto c'è una discussione fra
il nostro io presente e il nostro futuro
io futuro che ti prega di farla questa
dieta è dio presente che non è
assolutamente d'accordo io futuro parla
di benefici futuri quando la finira
questa dieta yo yo presente no ora le
argomentazioni che li ho presente usa e
necessita per decidere sono molto più
leggere di quelle di cui necessita l'io
futuro
le argomentazioni di che l'io presenti
usa sono più leggere di quelle che l'io
futuro usa e per arrivare al punto e per
adesso spiegarvi meglio come collegare
bene passato presente futuro uso un
termine che magari qualcuno di voi ha
già sentito
o magari no che chrono estesi a con
estesi ad un termine che mi è arrivato
un sacro e addosso negli ultimi anni
parlando di scelte e per cerca di
aiutare me stesso e gli altri a
scegliere meglio cos'è la crown estesi a
beh il edizione a che fare con un senso
per il futuro ma la crona estesi a è la
capacità di collegare bene passato
presente e futuro ea due belle
caratteristiche che mi hanno affascinato
uno è una capacità che gli animali non
hanno ed è tra l'altro un
approfondimento e una parola che è stata
approfondita da numerose neuro
scienziati tra cui and health al bing
per esempio che ha notato come pensare
al passato presente futuro attraverso
esami di risonanza magnetica ne abbiamo
sentito parlare tanto stasera sia
qualcosa di molto più profondo che
solamente ricordare o immaginare come
dire che noi umani quando pensiamo e
riusciamo ad entrare in uno stato che
accarezza il passato il presente il
futuro stiamo facendo un esercizio che
ha molte più conseguenze e
approfondimenti di quello che pensiamo a
prima vista la conosce sia
sostanzialmente è la capacità di
muoverci bene attraverso questi stati
dell'io perché il muoverci bene
attraverso questi stati è l'io ci porta
dei vantaggi in termini decisionali
il primo vantaggio per esempio quello di
recuperare la saggezza delle esperienze
passate
un altro vantaggio è quello di depurare
le nostre percezioni dall'emotività del
momento
un altro vantaggio è saper stimare bene
i costi coinvolti soprattutto le
conseguenze secondarie di quello che
decideremo
un altro vantaggio ancora è quello di
creare una situazione in cui possiamo
immaginare degli scenari pessimistici e
problematici a con cui fare i conti e
preparare di piani b
insomma sa per muoverci bene
quindi immaginare bene momenti diversi
ed entrarci dentro in maniera soggettiva
come se fossimo gli attori di un film
aiuta molto a prendere decisioni
migliori che probabilmente è quello che
cerchiamo un po tutti quanti nella
nostra vita di ogni giorno
questo è un esempio tipico guardare un
film bere una birra uscire fare
allenamento approfondire qualcosa come
mai noi non riusciamo a valutare bene i
vari momenti del io e decidere la cosa
che più coerente con il nostro progetto
globale piuttosto che con il nostro
progetto a breve termine
ecco la proposta che io volevo fare
stasera era quella di tre strumenti tra
strumenti lo dicevo all'inizio che hanno
anche una storia in parte antica in
parte un po meno antico comunque sono
stati rivisitati e rimodernati tra
strumenti che vi volevo proporre sono il
primo un esercizio che io chiamo oggi
domani o dopodomani tra l'altro la
moglie di jack welch ho visto che ha
ripreso anche questo esercizio
lo chiamo in un altro modo ma
sostanzialmente è uguale susy wells e e
dice questo successo situazione te
propone prendi un foglio di carta e
qualsiasi decisione qualsiasi bivio che
tu stia affrontando prova a chiederti le
conseguenze della decisione che stai
prendendo in un'ottica di breve medio e
lungo periodo
sostanzialmente come la domanda sarebbe
cosa succederà fra un giorno cosa
succederà fra un mese cosa succederà fra
un anno se prendo questa decisione è
quello che io vi raccomanderei che mi
raccomanda ray e di farlo in modo
scritto questo serve ad accrescere la
lungimiranza e a fare i conti con
l'emotività e a depurare le nostre
decisioni dall'emotività e l'emotività
occhio non sto parlando dell'istinto mi
sento qualcosa che abbiamo dentro di
innato e che probabilmente ci aiuta in
grandi in molte delle molte situazioni a
sopravvivere sto parlando dell'emotività
e l'emotività e qualcosa che è legato
alle sovrastrutture i ragionamenti che
facciamo su strutture che noi acquisiamo
e che ci rende possibile interpretare le
situazioni
l'emotività di solito non è una grande
consigliera sul breve termine
questo è il primo esercizio il secondo
esercizio si chiama con un nome strano
le ismo il ismo è una parola coniata da
simon taylor coleridge il poeta padre
del romanticismo britannico è
sostanzialmente si riferisce a quella
bizzarre strana maniera di scrivere o di
parlare che aveva per esempio cesare nel
de bello gallico parla di se stesso in
terza persona parlare o scrivere di sé
in terza persona si chiama in lace
modellismo deriva dal pronome
dimostrativo il
il latino lontano da chi parla lontano
da chi ascolta e so che vi può sembrare
bizzarro ma se non ci fosse stato un
signore che si chiama igor grossman che
è un professore di socio cognitivo ecco
si chiama occasione scienziato socio
cognitivo che analizza la saggezza gli
umani attraverso le varie culture quello
che scopre facendo con due gruppi di
confronto sulle ismo è questo se un
gruppo ragiona e riflette su decisioni
che deve prendere scrivendo e ragionando
in terza persona rispetto un gruppo di
confronto che ragiona e scrivi prima
persona dopo un po di tempo la capacità
di umiltà intellettuale di sviluppo di
opzioni e di capacità di compromesso e
quindi trovare soluzioni o di
intraprendere decisioni a questi bv più
sagge nel primo gruppo è più alta anche
qui naturalmente io come vi dicevo
all'inizio sono un testimone non vi
chiedo di credermi non è questo il mio
lavoro non devo convertire solo però vi
assicuro che scrivere in terza persona
di sé le attivamente i b li aiuta anche
in questo caso a diminuire il calore
emotivo e a prendere decisioni in
prospettiva migliore oltre ripetuto
diverse volte decisioni migliori
la cosa era una decisione migliore nella
mia accezione è la decisione che più
avvicina all'idea che avevo in testa la
tua vita
ali alla vita vera che tu vivrai e
quindi al tuo sistema valoriale nel
complesso il terzo e ultimo esercizio è
un esercizio che è di storica memoria
nel senso o meglio una derivazione è un
aggiornamento ne ha parlato ieri klein e
ho l'ho trovato molto intelligente come
spunto ma forse avrete sentito parlare
la premeditazione l'oro ma è una cosa
che marco aurelio seneca o epiteto
facevano la mattina la mattina si
alzavano questi signori e pensavano a
tutte le cose che sarebbero potute
andare a male durante il giorno
gli stoici avevano questo atteggiamento
francamente io apprezzo molto di più
rispetto a certe filosofia di super
mercato moderni che ti convincono che
tutto andrà bene tranne poi
comparire nel momento in cui tutto ti va
male dice mi avevi detto che andava
tutto bene ma va bene era per venderti
un corso per vendite un seminario per
vederti un evento ecco io e questo è
un'opinione personale non ho simpatia
per questo tipo di atteggiamenti mentre
invece ne ho molto per gli storici che
sostanzialmente partivano da un
pessimismo molto intelligenti
immaginifico per vivere la vita bene o
meglio
ecco la premeditazione la rom è la mamma
della premi dell'esercizio pre mortem
che è questo sostanzialmente un'autopsia
in assenza di cadavere tu hai un
obiettivo sviluppo un progetto dopo che
è sviluppato il progetto ipotizza tutte
le buone maniere in cui potrebbe andar
male è molto vicino o si si inserisce e
e assomiglia al project management
quindi o a riscone
quindi è molto nobile come come come
come origine questo tipo di questo tipo
di strumento
una volta che hai sviluppato tutti i
buoni modi in cui questo progetto può
andar male stratificarsi come si direbbe
nera lean production trovare le cause
analoghe dare un punteggio di
probabilità ed intervenire in base alla
tua energia e le tue possibilità con dei
piani alternativi e di piani b che ti
mettono al riparo appunto da kaos caso e
la cattiveria
ripeto è un autopsia in assenza di
cadavere ha un'alta efficienza e un
bassissimo costo
si tratta di sviluppare un sesto senso
come avvocato del diavolo per tutti
quelli che siamo gli showstoppers tutto
ciò che può fermare lo shock e tu volevi
fare e che vuole v che fosse la tua vita
bene di petto oggi domani e dopodomani
il lesmo e tecnica pre mortem
vi lascio con questa con questa domanda
nel senso che tutto quello che ho detto
stasera in questi diciotto minuti ha a
che fare con questo cosa siamo disposti
a fare oggi per il nostro io futuro e io
non ho una risposta naturalmente per il
pubblico possa averle eventualmente per
me e non per tutti allora mi domandavo
con cose a posto chiudere che vada bene
a tutti io credo che potremmo essere
d'accordo tutti quanti almeno su
se dobbiamo fare qualcosa oggi per il
nostro futuro
vale appena che facciamo qualcosa per
cui sia fiero
grazie ragazze buono no
[Applauso]
[Musica]